welcome to another edition of technology
Tuesday and today we're talking about
how to avoid getting ripped off on odesk
so I got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers all the way out of New
Zealand wrote in to say thanks to the
video make very informative I'd like to
commercialize an Android application and
I have no idea as to where to start I
live in New Zealand and no one will
overhear make an appt for less than one
hundred fifty dollars an hour so oh does
sounds pretty good just a question as a
newbie 20 desk how do I know that
whoever I hire isn't going to take my
money and run any new entrepreneur who's
trying to hire a team starts to worry
about whether it's a remote team or
somebody physically in your office and
there's a there is a big fear of hiring
somebody remote that I can't monitor
them they're not sitting right here in
front of my in front of me so I can't
see what they're doing and they're gonna
rip me off and I'm going to pay them in
they're going to be gone so how do you
minimize that chance on odesk i have
three strategies that will help you
number one look at the track record so
when i first joined odesk I thought of
it kind of like ebay where if you're
buying something from ebay you're buying
something from a seller something that
you really want you look at the person's
track record on ebay and the best
sellers really care about their track
record right they want people to give
them good ratings and on oh that's the
same thing happens after every time a
contract is finished people ask leave
feedback for each other so the the
contractor leaves feedback for the
contract e and vice versa and so if you
really want to reduce your risk I would
look at only hiring contractors who have
a really positive track record on Oda so
they've worked a lot of hours and they
have at least four out of five star
feedback from the people that they've
worked with in the past that way you've
kind of reduced your risk and you know
these people care about their work
they've been here before it's not their
first time here and they're likely going
to give you a good result number two is
start small I always start projects on
odesk on a small scale and build up and
what it does is it helps you start to
work with somebody and see if they can
deliver some results for you before
investing a huge amount of time and
dollars into this person and
also helps your girl can you work well
with this person or not because they may
have all the talents and skills in the
world but if you guys are clashing every
time and you don't work well together
then it's not going to be a good
long-term fit for your company so what I
try to do is you have this big idea for
your app I try to break it down into
chunks and figure out what can you get
in five hours so give somebody five
hours to help you get that first step
done whatever it is and just hire them
for that five hours and I usually end up
hiring multiple people to do that five
hours as the test to see do they milking
for the full five hours you order to do
it sooner are they communicating well
with me do I love the product that they
end up creating do they go above and
beyond they give me something great and
not just give me what I ask for and
that's a good little sample test to see
if you got the right person before you
invest this huge amount of time and
money into them so too it starts small
number three is no manual hours you have
an option to know desk when you're
hiring somebody on an hourly basis to
add manual hours that means their
computers not being tracked so whenever
somebody logs into odesk to work for you
they have to log in and say hey I'm
working for Evan now and immediately
their computer starts being tracked the
ODA starts taking screenshots of what
they're doing and it tracks their
keyboard and mouse movements so if
you're really anal and worried that this
person is ripping you off you can go in
and see what's happening on their
computer right are they actually working
for you or are they checking out an
episode of Twilight or watching harry
potter or listen to kanye whatever it is
so you can see if there aren't you
working for you but then you can turn
off manual hours and what manual hours
are is an option for the contractors to
put in time for your project without
seeing what happened on your computer so
this is usually if they lost connection
to the internet or they did work and
they forgot to log in but it's an
opportunity potential for them they rip
you off if they're just doing whatever
and I say well that took me 10 hours to
do but really only took them an hour and
you can't see because you haven't
tracked what's going on the computer so
as you build trust in a relationship you
can
you turn that on but for all new
projects I don't allow manual logging of
hours so in summary number one look at
the track record number to start small
and number three no manual hours if at
the end of the day you do all three of
these things and you still feel like
somebody ripped you off Oh des does have
a dispute resolution mechanism where you
can report this person to them and they
will then try to arbitrate it and try to
find a solution so it's not it's not
being completely ripped off there is
this middleman to kind of help you
through that process if you do feel like
you're being ripped off but hopefully by
following those three steps you won't
get ripped off and you'll find the right
team that helped you build your business
good luck with the app when it comes out
let me know I'd love to see it believe
for those of you watching like the
videos so you can support me by clicking
on a link in the description leave a
comment below let me know what you think
and click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon